good morning Hank it's Wednesday we seem
to have found ourselves in something of
a debt crisis and by we I don't mean
like the vlogbrothers I mean like the
planet I've already talked about
sovereign debt problems in Europe today
I want to talk about the purported
American debt crisis but first let me
define a few terms there are basically
two kinds of debt unsecured debt is debt
that you promise to pay back but uh you
know I have to take your word for it and
then there's collateralized debt like a
mortgage which is debt that you promised
to pay back and if you don't pay it back
I get your house
generally collateralized debt is safer
than unsecured debt which is why I like
mortgages tend to be less expensive than
credit cards although as we have lately
learned collateralized debt is not
always a good investment
another term gross domestic product is a
measure of like the total annual
economic output of a country in 2010 the
GDP of the United States was about
fourteen point six trillion dollars
that's a big number unfortunately our
total debt obligations are currently
also fourteen point six trillion dollars
this means that our debt to GDP ratio is
about 100 percent which could be worse
it's not good
so hey traditionally when governments
have a debt to GDP ratio over 90 percent
they tend to I mean not always but they
tend to default on that debt like they
tend to go bankrupt basically the
government tells its lenders we promised
we would pay you back when we were lying
sorry life is hard and full of
disappointment here's a Tootsie Pop just
getting there no Tootsie Pops this is
obviously a bad thing for the lenders
but it's also a bad thing for the
government because once you've proven
that you're the kind of country that
occasionally goes bankrupt people are
reluctant to lend you money at low
interest rates but it still happens all
the time in the last few centuries
hundreds of governments have defaulted
on their debt obligations and it doesn't
matter if the currency is backed by gold
or silver or promises it doesn't matter
all sovereign debt is essentially
unsecured debt if you want government
money by purchasing a Treasury bond they
don't have a house to pay you back with
and the price of gold and silver are so
far removed from their value as
commodities that they don't work as
currency backers either many countries
on the gold standard have defaulted on
their debt there is only one thing
backing currency in this world and that
is trust okay so I know in order to help
investors know whether something is
credit worthy there are these
independent nonpartisan credit rating
agencies like Standard & Poor's they
rate debt from triple-a on down and
generally just like individuals the
better your credit score the cheaper
your debt that's why Australia pays 4%
for tenure government bonds and Greece
pays 15%
sorry Greece
so the u.s. is well above that 90% debt
to GDP ratio that sets off alarm bells
and Congress just barely in the
stupidest game of chicken ever managed
not to default on our debt so the rating
agency Standard & Poor's was like you
know for the first time in US history
it's time to downgrade their debt from
triple-a to a A+ here's what you'd
expect to happen our debt being less
secure becomes much more expensive this
can be disastrous because as your debt
gets more expensive you need more money
to service it so you have to raise taxes
and cut spending which can slow the
economy and decrease government revenue
and then to make up the shortfall you
have to acquire evermore expensive debt
until you go bankrupt but here's the
thing Hank that's not what's happening
in the United States and the day since
Standard and Poor's downgraded our
credit rating our debt hasn't gotten
more expensive it's gotten cheaper
infecting the yule on some Treasury
bills is so low that the United States
is essentially getting paid to borrow
money why a few reasons first the whole
world economy is so volatile right now
that even if US debt is less safe than
it used to be it still seems more safe
than anything else to our so-called debt
crisis would almost completely be solved
by just not extending the Bush tax cuts
which will happen if Congress does
nothing and as you may have noticed
Congress is awesome at doing nothing
three the whole world is invested in the
American economy Hank by some estimates
half of the American money in
circulation is in circulation outside
the US and lastly at least for the time
being it's really important to countries
that make stuff like China that
countries that consume stuff like the
United States keep consuming so even
though our debts been downgraded it's
still much cheaper than lots of
countries with triple-a ratings Hank the
fact that the dollar remains the default
currency of the world and that people
still trust the United States to pay its
debts is worth trillions of dollars to
us annually that's probably not gonna go
away anytime soon but in the long run
every time we show an inability to get
things done politically or economically
we chip away at the world's faith in us
Hank I'll see you on Friday